something bad i think happened in this
country today i think vigilante's got a
signal that you can go out and do
whatever you want which i don't think is
going to be good but for a talk show
host who's about to go on vacation on a
debate show this is a dream
because all i have to do is read both
your statements today and we're off to
the races this is
this is you this decision is an
indictment of irresponsible laws that
make our society far more violent and
unsafe under the guise of personal
freedom and so-called self-defense chris
christie says
okay
justice was done in the written house
verdict renews our faith in the jury
system
who wants to go first i think i think
the real crisis here
that we are missing
uh in uh brownsville a 17-year-old can
get
a an assault rifle faster than he can
get a computer
this young man 17 year old it was
illegal for him to purchase the rifle
but it was legal for him to carry it
across state lines going into a
community looking for people that he
wanted to shoot or in some way disrupt
that is the real crisis what are we
doing to our children that you have an
access to these types of illegal for him
to buy it but okay for him to carry yes
yes yes
that's as crazy as wear your mask when
you walk into the restaurant but take it
off when you eat right it's it's just
crazy it really is well look i don't
think that our two statements are
necessarily as uh different as you as
you think what well no because look
look what i was talking about was
i look at it as a prosecutor
and
the laws are what they are you don't get
as a prosecutor to change the laws and
in the end the evidence they had did not
prove
what they needed to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt
so if you have an objection to the laws
and i think so eric was talking about if
you have an objection to the laws then
change the laws
um but don't bring a case where you
would okay
okay well that's you're looking at it
from a very and that's what my statement
was it's okay about price
let's
pull back to 30 000 feet now what about
the repercussions from this what about
the message this sends
to all the kids who like i say i think
this kid watched too many comic book
movies i think he wants to be some sort
of hero and i think there's lots of
in-cells out there like him who will do
the same thing
and it's just it's a tinderbox i mean i
read today 46 percent of people in this
country according to the zogby poll
think a civil war is likely
half the country thinks a civil war is
likely i don't think it's a great idea
to say
to people
you know what if the police are not
doing the job as they weren't at that
moment in kenosha
the answer can't be
then the citizens have full police
powers that can't be the response right
no i don't think
no and look i don't disagree with that
the point though is
that you can't use an individual case
to send a broader societal message if
the laws don't cover it so what you need
to do then if we're concerned about that
and we should be is then we need to go
after the laws and make sure we make it
very clear to people that you can't take
the law into your own hands but that's
what you need to do
not convict somebody
who under the law
was not entitled to be convicted
you know what i believe we must take
into our own hands
my plea to america we must take our
country back
we are allowing the fringe elements
in both of these conversations to really
hijack what everyday americans want we
want safe cities educate our children
and to be gainfully employed when you
have this division
that is just ripping us ripping us apart
when i'm really concerned uh there is a
i believe there's an anarchist group in
this country
the only desire is is to continue to
pull out our cities apart when i saw
police vehicles being firebombed when i
saw the destruction of property that's
happening we have a place in portland
where there's a city in a city this is
america there's only one country called
america there's not multiple countries
they're talking about a group on the
left or on the right or above
far
there's nothing wrong with being being
pragmatic is progressive i'm progressing
i want to close i want to deal with our
criminal justice system that's unfair i
want to close riker's island but darn it
i want to close the pipeline that feeds
rikers island 30 of those children this
is dyslexic
[Applause]
i think you just heard why he won
because i think despite these divisions
that we're talking about in the country
which are very real
there is still a large section of this
country that says just talk common sense
to me
you